[Applauso]
ciao
[Musica]
io voglio dirvi che quando scrivo sono
una persona molto molto molto felice
significa essere su una specie di
precipizio no c'è l'attrazione del vuoto
sembra di fare l'equilibrista e per
tenere il il visivo sul circo
quando uno scrive a volte si sente anche
un clown perché rivelare la propria
intimità ti fa sentire ridicolo
certe volte anche se invece ti ridicolo
non c'è nulla sta di fatto che tutto ciò
a una sorgente un po come i clown che
portano dentro delle profonde ferite
un dolore vedete il cappio io ho
cominciato a scrivere perché ho perso
mio amico quando ero adolescente
penso si suicidò eravamo coetanei
avevamo vissuto banco a banco le scuole
medie e l'inizio delle superiori poi la
vita la scuola di portare lontano e
quella ferita è diventata una specie di
uragano di terremoto che mi ha fatto
cominciare a scrivere pensieri ingenui
emozioni un po scialba che dovevo
cominciare a gestire in quella fase non
leggevo molto qualche fumetto qualche
rivista che mio padre faceva capitare
per casa pochi libri amavo la strada
sentivo che fosse il palcoscenico
eccellente
un po come poi più tardi ho scoperto
sentisse anche bukowskiano la strada il
più bel palcoscenico non si paga allo
spettatore non si paga il biglietto
ebbene io per strada giocavo a pallone
poi entrava in casa guardavo calcio alla
tv giocavo per strada
guardavo il calcio in tv e mina mi
accompagnava sempre mina è un
giornalista italiano che per me è stato
decisivo ed è quell omino vestito in
chiaro quei baffetti un po così quando
guardavo mina mi rendevo conto che lui
non raccontava solo storie di calcio o
meglio non solo storie di sportivi ma
raccontava storie la vita il cine
ma la letteratura e in quella foto mina
e con robert de niro cassius clay o
mohammed ali sergio leone e gabriel
garcía márquez
io comincio a capire che probabilmente
posso vivere raccontando storie è un po
come frankestein junior non si può fare
si può fare
si può vivere raccontando da adolescente
ovviamente non possedeva un linguaggio
ricco forbito consapevole non era un
magnate come syryza incrinano il
racconto di orson wells non ero smart
talentuoso come l'accoppiata di jack
lemmon e walter matthau che andavano in
prima pagina così con uno schiocco di
dita non avevo la lungimiranza del
personaggio di humphrey bogart nel film
l'ultima minaccia che racconta una
storia ispirata pulitzer e al telefono
lui contrasta il ruggito del suo
contendente dicevo è la stampa bellezza
e non ci puoi fare niente
io ho cominciato da dallo scantinato di
questo mestiere
entrando al circolo della stampa che era
in villa comunale a napoli e chiedendo
alla coordinatrice del circolo della
stampa signora io voglio fare il
giornalista
da dove iniziò e la signora mi risponde
accarezzandomi vaio belle mamma o
giornalista o fa solo finirò giornalista
dicendomi con grande affetto
se tuo padre non è un uomo potente di
questo mestiere
se tu non appartiene a una corporazione
questo mestiere tu non lo farai mai e io
in quel momento ho raccolto la sfida
ho detto vediamo se davvero non lo farò
mai
i primi gradi le prime collaborazioni
gratis erano appunto alla scoperta di
questa vita e parallelamente studiando
lettere moderne mi rendevo conto di
quanto bisognasse imparare e dei
sacrifici indispensabili da compiere
vedete dante perché quando studiavo alle
superiori
io ho preso un diploma di perito edile
la docente di italiano diceva ragazzi
dante che lo studio di affare non vi
servirà mai
oggi noi stabiliamo quali sono i vostri
discendenti
il miur ha sagittario e in quella fase
io sono ancora combattuto si assecondare
il desiderio di scrivere o assecondare
la voglia di fare architettura poi nel
tempo così come dimostra la foto allo
stadio san mamès di bilbao
ho capito che l'architettura era più una
fascinazione visiva per cui decido di
iniziare a buttarmi nel giornalismo e in
quella voragine in bianco e nero che
vedete è che testimonia il crollo e
l'incendio e la morte di 11 persone al
quadrivio di secondigliano nell'inverno
del 91
io mi rendo conto davvero di che
significa fare questo mestiere e come si
deve fare
incomincia a fare i primi diciamo scoop
comincia a litigare con un po di piccoli
politici e mi sento dire tu alimenti un
bravo giornalista o ti uccidono come
giancarlo siani
ovviamente questa consapevolezza al
giorno per giorno aumenta soprattutto
quando entri nel carcere di poggioreale
per la prima volta per raccontare ancora
una volta un evento dedicato ai detenuti
e ti trovi a intrattenerti con le
guardie carcerarie che ti accompagnano
allo spaccio per bere un po d'acqua per
prendere un biscotto e ti dicono le otto
vani detto venite con me e gli dici non
mi chiamate dottore chiamatemi sono
gianni dotto verità ci mancherebbe non
sono laureato quindi chiamatemi sono
gianni come fare i giornalisti amici
della wsr reati e gli spieghi che per
fare il giornalista devi raccogliere
notizie buone e saperle raccontare in
questa galassia voi potete vedere un po
delle testate con cui ho collaborato o
continua a collaborare ancora e il
titolo dice anche che spesso si lavora
gratis
certo non per sua volontà ma sei
costretto a inseguire
il diritto di essere pagato il rispetto
di essere retribuito ovviamente tutta
questa galassia ti dà nel tempo una
grande consapevolezza ma la
consapevolezza maggiore tula ricevi
quando fai le esperienze dirette
ora questa rosa di rockstar popstar nomi
importantissimi del cinema e della
cultura non è disgiunta nelle mie
emozioni dalle persone comuni che ogni
giorno mi trovo a intervistare linee
potrete individuare qualcuno
il premio oscar paolo sorrentino durante
la presentazione di un suo film o
accanto shirin neshat una visual artist
cineasta iraniana che non può rientrare
nel suo paese d'origine per i contenuti
delle sue creazioni artistiche
poi ci sono non so julian temple adria
maven che ha diretto i pink floyd a
pompei massive attack e proprio nella
foto grande vedete col panama bianco
david gilmour uomo simbolo e l'eredità
se vogliamo assieme a waters dei pink
floyd
ebbene in quella foto vi racconto di
quando ho rischiato l'arresto per
compiere quell'intervista perché i
poliziotti che come vedete ci
impediscono di dialogare volevano farsi
un self con la rock star mentre tu
invece sei lì per fare il tuo mestiere è
raccontare ai lettori che significa fare
rock sotto il vesuvio da precario da
decentrato rispetto a dove il giornale
davvero nasce e agisce e li vedete due
prime pagine degli spettacoli di
repubblica
dicevo da precario tu insisti ci credi
perché da ragazzina hai sentito qualcosa
di tellurico dentro di potente e quindi
dice ok io non sono un madrelingua
inglese magari l'intervista con michel
gondry la facciamo via mail
ma la devo portare a termine e prendi la
prima pagina di repubblica
allo stesso modo con rufus wainwright
quando diventa uno dei super ospiti del
sanremo di fabio fazio tu insisti anche
se hai lasciato l'università e non ti
sei laureato ogni giorno devi studiare
cinema musica
letteratura pittura poesia altrimenti
l'intervista con rufus sewell write
non la riesce a portare a termine in
tutte queste avventure capita di dover
adattare il linguaggio e quindi la
formula espressiva deve essere in
costante movimento come sia in costante
movimento to coi polmoni con gli
incontri con i viaggi e le pubbliche
relazioni sono un altro aspetto di
questo movimento che non sei costretto a
fare ma ti diverte fare pubbliche
relazioni magari per registi di cinema
per attori teatrali per musicisti per
festival
ma la vera essenza di te che scrivi
perché quello che siamo
prima o tardi emerge si manifesta e ci
devi fare i conti
così come avevo sentito quell'impulso da
adolescente arriva la scrittura pura
vulcanica come può essere lo stromboli e
quindi ti ritrovi a pubblicare
finalmente la tua prima raccolta di
versi le piume degli angeli scemi e il
titolo c'entra sempre col circo non vi
dico perché incominci a fare anche delle
performance di poesia con musicisti le
fai in luoghi magnifici della tua città
a napoli tipo al parco archeologico del
posillipo o le fai al museo madre
facendo performance improvvisando tra
musica elettronica visual art e poesia e
sotto ritrovate se avete buona memoria
visiva shirin neshat perché per lei e
con lei abbiamo fatto una performance si
è mai almamegretta nel museo madre o
vedete un'immagine di un club di new
york da dove nasce un po la spoken word
la poesia le slam poetry e ti ritrovi lì
a recitare in lingua italiana
quindi raccontando storie a un po quello
che magari non ti capisce nel linguaggio
ma ti capisce nel corpo vi dicevo di
quanto si muove il linguaggio e di
quante formule di scrittura ci siano c'è
sempre un enigma quando tu scrivi
chi è più in it ma di liberato in questi
ultimi tempi da un punto di vista
musicale
io ho voluto raccontare tutto quello che
c'è dentro il progetto deliberato e
l'enigma è anche un editoria perché da
un lato non ti pagano da un lato ci sono
dei misteri nei contratti da un lato tu
che hai lavorato per i primi dieci anni
nella galassia del giornalismo senza mai
essere pagato mai dieci anni nella vita
di una persona metteteli in fila mai
essere pagato sei disposto perché ci
credi in questa storia a scrivere un
libro senza ricevere alcun compenso di
anticipo e passato quasi un anno dal
libro forse a natale ricevo qualcosina
mi interessava però raccontarvi un altro
aspetto che quasi una capriola nel
linguaggio per chi scrive da sempre e
per chi tiene sempre in tasca un
quadernino e la penna si può raccontare
anche non scrivendo anche senza parole
un po come gli attori che non
necessariamente devono esprimersi con la
voce ma possono recitare con la mimica e
quindi dal racconto scritto ho
cominciato a fare dei racconti visivi
cioè street foto perché i paesaggi le
persone che incontriamo i mari
attraverso i quali notiamo sono un
racconto ci sono delle storie in tutto
quello che vedono i nostri occhi
questa è una storia per esempio
dell'empire state building di new york
ma qui c'è una storia altrettanto
disperata e tenerissima di due
innamorati perduti strafatti in una
piazza del centro storico di napoli e
napoli ti parla mi parla e sento di
essere un medium per raccontarla anche
quando e piovosissima ed è notte non c'è
nessuno per strada e toledo e la sua
vertebra antica che però vuole esige di
essere raccontata come esige o pretende
di essere raccontato il crimine di una
persona che ti trovi a incontrare al bar
ma la cronaca ovviamente vuole essere
raccontata e dell'urgenza che ogni
giorno noi cerchiamo nelle notizie e
questa signora che va verso l'isola di
chios nel mediterraneo la terra di omero
mentre tu sei spensierato e vuoi fare
dieci giorni di vacanza ti chiama e ti
dice raccontami tutte queste esperienze
questo accumulo di vita di emozioni che
è difficile trattenere anzi è
impossibile non le vuole trattenere a un
certo punto mi hanno fatto dire guarda
che tu puoi raccontare innanzitutto la
tua città e per paradosso che possa
apparirvi mi sono inventato un nuovo
mestiere cioè fare performance on the
road dedicate a napoli na if fuori dagli
schemi fuori dal prevedibile fuori dal
senso comune
naif e ve lo fa vedere l'immagine che
abbina diego maradona alla vergine maria
nel borgo della sanità naif perché
portando in giro le persone recitando
canzoni pittura teatro cinema
letteratura
tutti i racconti l'essenza del golfo e
questo sentimento da flaneur un po
citando baudelaire che uno dei poeti che
più amo divagare senza una meta
perché sai che comunque arriverà in una
storia e la racconterà i quella foto in
bianco e nero vi testimonia amy
testimonia di quanto è indispensabile
continuare a vivere così perché quella
foto racconta un viaggio a new york
ero lungo bowery incontro jr che uno dei
fotografi tissi più importanti al mondo
contemporaneo facciamo amicizia
c'è empatia all'istante e j armi dice io
voglio che tu faccia parte del mio
progetto una monumentale installazione
fotografica che è in esposizione al
brooklyn museum ora e io sono in quella
foto
questo significa avere dosi di grinta
interminabili perché quella che davvero
ti alimenta giorno per giorno non
rinunciare mai alla tua curiosità mai ma
mai avere un allegria costante ma non
perché ce la devi avere perché ti senti
un clown semplicemente perché sei tu e
ti riconosci e tutte le esperienze con
le rockstar o con j ar o con le persone
comuni
le poesie i libri senza avere nessun
anticipo ti devono essere consapevole
che questo è un momento di gioia
costante infine come si fa a non essere
partigiani di se stessi per essere
partigiani di se stessi ci vuole tanta
tantissima
credetemi tantissima l'esistenza
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]